this rogue star has been traveling the
universe and
now it's finally entering our solar
system
but this isn't just any regular star
it's known as a quasi-star
and is one of the biggest stars in
existence
what would happen if this star entered
our solar system
and how would earth be affected
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a quasi star entered our solar system
quasi stars aren't just regular stars
they're powered by black holes
the theory is that the original star
would have been
so massive that the core started to
collapse
normally a supernova would happen at
this stage but
instead the explosion is absorbed by the
outer layers of the star
and a black hole forms at its core
the black hole then feeds on this star
for
thousands of years slowly absorbing it
now what would happen if this deadly
star
came toward our solar system
first let's understand just how
massive this star is to put it in
perspective
our sun is the largest object in our
solar system
at 1.3 million kilometers in diameter
that may seem massive but it's really
nothing
just 5.2 light years away from us
there's another star known as ui scooty
which is 1700 times larger than our sun
[Music]
pretty big huh but this quasi star
is even bigger than that this
massive star has a diameter of 10
billion kilometers more than seven
thousand times the size of our sun
so yeah this thing is an absolute unit
and now it's coming for us
if a quasi-star did enter our solar
system
we'd start to notice it much sooner than
you might think
this one star would be as bright as an
entire galaxy
not only that but it would be as
luminous as at least
100 000 suns
so the closer the star would get the
brighter
everything would appear on earth
but unfortunately this star wouldn't
just be giving us
brighter days than we're used to
as soon as the star entered our solar
system planets
asteroids and any other objects would
likely be thrown out of orbit
this could cause epic meteor showers for
us here on earth
thousands of asteroids could all end up
crashing into our planet
and if a planet were lucky enough not to
get thrown out of orbit
it would eventually still get engulfed
by the quasi-star
the quasi-star would go all across our
solar system
it might engulf neptune and then even
our massive planets like saturn
and jupiter it would continue this
journey
until it reached earth granted
humanity would be extinct by this point
due to the incredible temperatures of
the star
and then the planet would quickly heat
up
once it hit 260 degrees the atmosphere
would become
steam and carbon dioxide getting hotter
at 760 degrees
sulfur dioxide would be produced and
earth would continue to heat up until
the crust and mantle were completely
vaporized
and the entire planet was engulfed by
the star
and as if this star hasn't caused enough
trouble
it could eventually become a super
massive black hole
this would be after its black hole core
finished
swallowing the entire star
okay now that we have this super massive
black hole
how about we make it fight a white hole
but we'll leave that story for another
what if